Can I just, erm...
Don't... I don't know what to...
Erm...
I think, er...
I don't know what to say.
I'm sorry.
You don't know sometimes
what to say
and you're basically
walking on eggshells.
Sometimes it can shock people.
Someone says,
"Are you having a good day?"
They just expect you to say,
"Yes, I'm OK."
And I've said, "No, I'm not."
And some people can get taken aback,
"Oh, oh, oh."
And I think there's
the fear of saying the wrong thing.
You know, "What do I know
about mental health?"
I was diagnosed
with anorexia nervosa,
body dysmorphic disorder
and obsessive compulsive
disorder back in 2013.
And on Friday, the 29th of August,
2014, I tried to take my own life.
My name's Harkiran.
I'm Sandeep's mum.
Mother, is it?
Best friend.
And best friend.
Dave first joined a MINT session
when he was struggling
with his mental health.
And from there, we kind of -
in a strange way - hit it off,
I think.
It was love at first sight.
I like to think of it
that way!
I'm Dr Will Murcott
and I'm a mental health nurse
and senior lecturer
with The Open University.
For me, listening is
at the top of the list.
I think that's the first
and most important step.
If you can, active listening -
repeating back some of the things
that they've said to you so
that they can feel and realise
that they're being helped.
That first initial
conversation that you had with me,
when my mum and dad sat me down,
that's when the bubble popped
for me.
That's when I thought,
at that very moment, that
someone's noticing how I'm feeling,
someone is noticing and having
an oversight of my pain,
just asking how you are.
It was so crucial and so important
to me at that moment.
Ask twice, you know,
"Are you OK?"
"Yeah, I'm all right."
"But, no, are you really OK?"
And then it's like,
"Well, no, actually, I'm not."
I think there is an urge
to try and problem-solve
and do something,
and there's almost a need sometimes
to be able to fix a problem
or a person,
and sometimes that's not the right
thing to do in that situation.
People aren't necessarily
looking for answers.
People want to be heard.
One of the things
I've learned as a mental health
professional is that often if I try
and set goals or have my own needs
and wants and desires
for how somebody should get better,
they are usually wrong.
And so, from my point of view,
it's working with a person
at their pace and trying to
understand how they want to move.
You can suggest go to your GP,
you can suggest support groups,
you can suggest people
take in an activity.
You can go and join in
that activity with them
so they're not feeling alone
with that.
One size does not fit all.
You had a really great idea, didn't
you? The family trusted circle.
Yes, so what we do, we go
out the family environment and go to
a coffee shop or just sit there,
all four of us,
actually doing our pos and negs.
"What's been your positive
for the whole month?
"What's been your negative
for the month?"
We spend a lot of time
insulting each other.
We just send each other
little videos or...
"Yeah, I've been watching that,"
and just little clips.
Everybody's at the click
of a button now.
- You're in my pocket.
- Yeah.
If they're really
struggling and at breaking point,
emergency phone lines out there.
- Samaritans.
- And Samaritans as well.
They need to know that...
There is someone out there.
..there is support out there.
And it's so hard,
so hard to see that when...
You are in a dark place.
..when you're in a dark place, yeah.
One of the scary things
is that kind of pressure of,
"What do I do if...?"
because there can be nothing more
scary than having somebody talk
to you about ending their life,
harming themselves in some way.
Really, the person needs to know
as well at what point you'll find
something acceptable or unacceptable
and then have to do something
or involve somebody else.
I always try and get that
conversation done as soon
as I can to say, "Look, you know,
I will never breach your confidence,
"but if there are things
that worry me, then...
"..then I may have to do
something about that."
And again, that's absolutely OK
because the person will thank you
for it afterwards.
Let people know that,
"I'm here and we're going to do
this together," so if that means,
"Right, me and you, we're going
to make an appointment at the GP,
we'll go together
and we'll do this together."
And it's about being
in the mud together.
You have to keep your own
emotional batteries charged up,
cos when they're drained out,
you can't help anybody else
and you struggle to function,
let alone just trying
to look after yourself.
The plane and the oxygen mask -
put your oxygen mask on first.
Self-care is
the number-one priority, I think.
So, I don't think
you can actually fail,
and that's something
that I would really push to
everyone who's helping someone
with mental health struggles,
is you haven't failed, you cannot
fail, but you can do something.
Trust... Again, trust
your instincts. Be yourself.
The right thing
is probably what you first felt,
and that could have been sitting
and listening, just nodding,
or it could have been responding,
"Tell me more about that."
So, not to over-worry, not to
overthink, but there is support
out there and there are people
that will listen to you
and give you advice and guidance.
And it's important to talk.
Oh, my God,
it's so important to talk.
Very important to talk.
We end most chats with,
"Love you, man."
You know, it's...
Yeah, it's good to...
It's good to have someone
like Josh in my life.
- It makes my life better.
- And vice versa.